welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we host webinars every
Tuesday my name is Loretta Crowley and
I'm here today to talk to you about
managing Chrome browser updates in your
enterprise as enterprises look to adopt
Chrome browser or make it its primary
browser the topic of how to manage
updates comes up often in today's
session we'll talk through some of your
options for managing updates and give
you some tips so that you can best
deploy Auto updates in your environment
before we get started let's talk a
little bit about why the browser is
growing in importance you may have
already noticed some shifts and your own
enterprise that impact the way you think
about the web browser
research shows that users leverage 22
cloud and SAS based apps across three
devices to get their jobs done we did
some recent research with Forrester that
revealed the average user spends about
1/3 of their day in the web browser and
there's an even more connected group of
users that spend upwards of four hours a
day getting work done in their browser
we'll talk about that group of users in
a little bit and we know this trend is
likely on the rise 81% of IT
professionals
report that they'll continue to view
cloud and SAS app adoption as the
priority when they explore the adoption
of new apps in their environment I
talked about this idea of a more
connected type of worker at Google cloud
we call these members of the work force
cloud workers these cloud workers are
highly reliant on browser and web web
applications to get their jobs done and
also have a highly remote and mobile
working style one in four workers are
actually already considered cloud
workers and some
you might consider yourself cloud
workers because of cloud-based app
adoption and the growth of cloud workers
the importance of the browser has
elevated across the enterprise's the
browser is no longer a passive tool used
to browse data it's not the crux of
where business users go to access the
critical applications they need to be
productive I know when I go to work in
the morning the browser is the first
thing that I open and for people like me
the browser has actually become my
desktop it's the place I go to get my
work done and to be productive because
people are spending so much more time in
their browser it's more important than
ever before for IT to really have a
strategy around the benefits of the
modern browser when we talk to our
customers who are adopting Chrome
browser in their enterprise the benefits
that they find are really in three key
areas let's talk about management Chrome
browser makes it simple for IT to manage
through their existing management tools
for example you can manage hundreds of
policies through group policy we make
these templates available and I'll show
you exactly where you can find those
later on for Mac users we offer
documentation on how you can manage
their P lists and we also offer the
option of managing your browser
instances right from the cloud in the
Google admin console we'll be opening up
this capability to IT admins that aren't
Google admins today in the coming months
at that point we'll have a single
destination for IT to manage Chrome
browser instances across all of the
different platforms in their environment
security is also critical Chrome browser
is constantly increasing built-in
security capabilities for this broader
user base and those benefits extend to
the enterprise as well for example the
Safe Browsing service offered by Google
helps users be prevented from visiting
infected or potentially malicious
websites and our sandboxing and site
isolation capabilities
ensures that threats cannot spread from
within or between tabs making sure that
these threats cannot spread across your
network with I t's ability to enforce
and add additional policies and controls
enterprises find that they can get
chrome to a secure state that meets even
the most stringent security requirements
and of course there's your happy users
Chrome browser offers a familiar
experience that your users love so they
can pick up right where they left off
and be productive across all of the
different devices that they use in their
working bay at the end of the day
whether we're talking about web browsers
or any technology decision we know that
IT is constantly balancing two very
important requirements security and the
user experience while IT teams and
security teams might see this lockdown
state as an ideal state from a security
perspective user experience simply can't
fall to the wayside and we know the IT
folks agree in a recent Forrester survey
73% of IT professionals said that
employee experience is a top priority
when they make technology decisions in
their enterprise Chrome browser really
helps IT teams strike this balance
between users and security and auto
updates are no exception you're here
today to learn more about the Chrome
browser update model and is a great
example of how IT teams can promote both
the latest security capabilities while
offering a great user experience
automatic updates are standard for
Chrome browser and let's look exactly
why that's our primary recommendation
for enterprises Chrome's commitment to
delivering continuous enhancements
provides a fast and easy way to keep
your employees productive all of that is
alongside
timely vulnerability mitigations and new
security capabilities so with auto
updates running your enterprises get
fast and instant access to the latest
browser with the most advanced
protections available to them and with
Auto updates
you eliminate the need for IT to handle
manual patching efforts freeing up I t's
time and resources and there's great
benefits for users too for example they
can get an optimized experience on the
modern web apps that they use by using
the latest version of the browser and if
all your users are running on the same
version of the browser it makes it easy
for you to handle any potential support
issues or challenges that might arise
and for the users the updates themselves
are seamless it just takes a simple
refresh and they're guaranteed to be on
the latest version that's available to
them and for our customers who've opted
into Chrome Enterprise support they get
24/7 access to chrome experts to help
them with their deployment and browser
installations and they'll have the peace
of mind knowing that their users are on
the latest supported version of the
browser you might be wondering how
Chrome browsers update model compares to
other modern or legacy browsers chrome
sets the pace in browser updates for the
industry but we'll let the metrics speak
from themselves
we always encourage fast and frequent
Auto updates as a best practice but we
know some enterprises have unique
testing or internal requirements that
might make it challenging to stay on
automatic update models so we do have
some options available for you to manage
this process let's take a look at these
more closely even if your organization
has a desire to benefit from auto
updates you could have some internal
challenges that make this difficult some
of those common things include concerns
around application compatibility unique
testing requirements change management
processes that you're required to follow
internal security reviews and even
regulatory requirements if for these
reasons or others Auto updates aren't
exactly for your organization you can
turn off the auto update functionality
we just want to make sure that you're
aware that it's a bit of a trade-off you
may not be running with the latest
security releases and when it comes to
UI changes or other enhancements your
users may not be getting the latest and
greatest experience that we have to
offer we'll also cover some options you
have for looking ahead to the beta
Channel because there are some great
ways that you can take advantage of
early access to that beta Channel to get
ahead on some of the testing or internal
requirements that might make auto
updates a little bit more viable for
your organization let's talk about the
chrome release cycles so you know
exactly what to expect the chrome
release cycle runs roughly every six
weeks
moving from beta into stable in time for
the next beta release the ideal time for
you to test your apps is during those
first two weeks of a beta release if you
find any issues with chrome you should
immediately report them to Google within
this two-week window that will help us
ensure that we're delivering a stable
version that's going to be great for you
and your users and Chrome browser has
multiple release channels you have
access to all of these and you can
access them as early as your
organization wants by leveraging the
various release channels and testing you
can be in an auto update world while
skits still having the opportunity to
adequately test in your enterprise all
of these channels ranging from Chrome
Canary across to Chrome stable are
available to you at a minimum we
recommend that your organization
leverage is the beta version for testing
internally each stable release marks a
major version release and each chrome
platform has a different stable rollout
plan it's important to note that this
can vary based on circumstances but this
is a good general guide that can help
you with your planning today we're
mostly going to focus on desktops the
desktop consists of three main platforms
Windows Mac and Linux Linux is ramped up
100% immediately Mac and Windows on the
other hand follow a staged rollout plan
starting at 5% moving to 15% going up to
50% and then reaching 100% you may
notice this rollout process within your
organization if you're using Auto
updates this staging process allows for
any potential issues to be detected
early in a sense we're offering your
organization a built-in safeguard for
auto updates we've talked about testing
quite a bit here the how should you go
about internal testing we have a few
tips for you first off you should be
leveraging release notes that are
available on the Help Center to help you
understand what's new they're released
within a few weeks of the beta release
and they highlight any new functionality
that could be of interest to your
enterprise in some cases we'll even
highlight future changes coming in
upcoming releases so that you can plan
ahead we also suggest that you enable a
group of users within your organization
to become testers you might be surprised
at how some users are interested and
wanting to be a part of these early
testing groups we also recommend that
you consider some automated testing and
feet around features and applications
that are leveraging chrome overall it's
a good idea to invest your internal
testing resources in chrome as well we
know a lot of organizations have
dedicated teams that focus on testing
on-premise apps the browser itself
sometimes gets forgotten and methey with
each update Chrome browser is changing
so how's yours really as your users rely
more on the browser it makes sense to
have some resources that have ownership
over the testing of their apps on Chrome
browser and the browser itself no matter
what the best thing is to find a process
or cycle that works for your
organization you might find that auto
updates are actually easier for your
team to manage than you thought if we
look at a great way we see some
organizations segment their users and
maximize their use of updates
looks something like this there might be
a small group of select beta users
they're serving as an internal source of
QA really testing out the browser latest
release on the applications and things
that they do on a daily basis then the
majority of your users will be on the
stable version running auto updates
always making sure that they're on the
latest and greatest version of Chrome
then you might have a smudge smaller
group of exception users that happen to
be pin on a version of chrome again we
really encourage this being the
exception and we'll talk a little bit
more about that among all of your
options across the board you can
approach updates with chrome in four
different ways if you haven't caught on
yet our recommendation is to keep Auto
updates on and enabled it's the default
and we make additional policies
available to help you make sure these
updates actually take place for example
you can use a policy that designates
users to refresh their browser within a
given time frame that makes sure they
don't miss any critical updates because
they haven't refreshed or restarted
their browser in a while another option
you have is to disable auto updates but
issue periodic updates on your own
most organizations handle this through a
third-party software distribution tool
using manual GPO updates or other
processes you can also disable updates
entirely pinning your user to a specific
version as discussed before this is
really only recommended to be an
exception and we want to make sure that
you're limiting this so that folks are
getting the maximum security and user
experience benefits from chrome in some
cases you might need to take a mixed
approach you might need to have some of
these pins users based on a very
specific business need whether it's an
application requirement or some sort of
security and compliance reason while
your broader group can still be
benefiting from the use of auto updates
or scheduled updates
we're going to quickly show you how you
can get started managing updates I'm
going to visit chrome comm slash
Enterprise which is the download page
that includes all of the downloads files
and templates and more that you need to
manage Chrome browser in your enterprise
let's focus on Windows you'll see that
we have enterprise bundles and
standalone MSI files which you would
need to come retrieve if you decide to
disable a lot of updates we make
templates available for Google updates
this is for updates across Google
services including chrome on the next
tab you can see documentation that we
make available for managing those
updates it'll guide you through the
downloading process and the process for
installing templates into the windows
policy definitions folder on the next
tab you'll see some github files that
one of our chrome deployment specialists
is made available this script will kick
off the download of the GPA Oh templates
unzip and install them into the windows
policy definitions folder this is an
alternative to the manual steps outlined
in the previous steps from here you'll
be able to view policy options around
disabling auto updates dive into policy
settings to set auto updates manage
timing of your auto updates and you can
enforce policies like the one that
prompts your users to restart to trigger
a browser update
let's suppose you've decided that you
want to use software distribution for
your initial deployment of Chrome this
is a common scenario the steps would
look a little something like this
you would go through an initial
discovery process to understand what's
currently on your desktops perhaps there
are users of versions of Chrome that
were self installed by users once you've
done this discovery you'll want to build
out your enterprise chrome package using
the MSI that we saw when we visited
chrome comm slash enterprise the next
thing you want to do is identify a group
of pilot users to install this on based
on the feedback you receive and any of
the change management or release
management processes you need to go
through you can move through that step
then you'll move on to installing chrome
into your production environment once
you've done that rollout you can focus
on updates and really put yourself in
maintenance mode around the browser as
you can see if you've completed that
cycle and decided to leave other updates
on you'll really only need to focus on
the feedback and the updates and you'll
have the assurance that every six weeks
your enterprise is getting the latest
and greatest updates if you decide to
disable auto updates so you can plan to
issue periodic updates but you look at
repeating many of these same steps again
for each time you update as you can see
you can get significant time savings by
staying on the auto update model another
topic that comes up around updates is
around the ATM admx templates that we
make available with each release new GPO
templates become available that's often
because we're introducing new policies
around management and control so if you
see that there's new policies that you
want to take advantage of in a given
release you'll need to visit that same
Chrome enterprise site and install these
files separately at the end of this
session I'll provide you a link to where
you can see an updated policy list which
should serve as a great guide for you
to review when you want to determine
when you're ready to go in and install
new template updates another question we
get is around legacy browser support
legacy browser support is an extension
available to enterprises right within
the enterprise bundle it's a great tool
that allows you to predetermine which
set of legacy apps legacy URLs will open
dynamically in a legacy browser for
example Internet Explorer enterprises
love legacy browser support because it
allows them to keep their users primary
browsing experience within chrome
browser where they can benefit from all
the security capabilities and access
their modern apps then when a user goes
to use a legacy app they'll
automatically get redirected into
Internet Explorer and once they're ready
to browse or use a different app they'll
be redirected dynamically right back
into Chrome this is great for these
scenarios where an enterprise is living
partway between a modern and a legacy
app world this extension is updated
periodically but it's not included in
Auto updates so you just want to make
sure that you're planning on reviewing
those updates and distributing them
accordingly
as it makes sense for your organization
legacy browser support is an example of
one popular extension and it's a google
extension but we know in your enterprise
you probably have quite a few
third-party extensions that your users
love to use in their environment to help
make them more productive managing
updates for third-party extensions comes
up sometimes to extension management is
built into the curl Enterprise bundle
there's a variety of different policies
that really lets you control access to
extensions you can even get very
granular around permission controls that
are allowed around these extensions but
when it comes to updating them you have
a few choices the webstore can allow for
auto updates or you can decide to pin
extensions in your environment your
organization's should really decide what
approach makes sense around managing and
updating the extensions in their buyer
we've covered a lot of information but
what can your teams be doing today what
early next steps can you take well for
starters it's a great conversation to
have around what your bandwidth and
tolerance is for new updates within your
organization there's really a trade-off
that happens do you want the security
enhancements guaranteed with the latest
version of the browser or would you
rather control timing of updates on your
own your team should spend a little bit
of time getting familiar with some of
the release cycles I mentioned today
really determine how you can possibly
maximize testing within your
organization based on the different
release cycles you can also see if
there's an opportunity to segment your
users in a lot of organizations there's
a group of users that would do great on
auto updates that way if you're deciding
to manage or pin updates it's really for
an isolated group of users that'll take
the burden off of your team when it
comes to managing and securing the
browser and of course you'll want to
make sure that you're reviewing the
enterprise release notes that we make
available to you often and early it'll
give you great visibility and two
changes coming Ahead's that your
organization can plan accordingly I've
talked about a lot of information today
and I wanted to end our session with
some useful links that you might find
beneficial chrome comm slash Enterprise
is the page that we visited in the demo
where you got to see all of the
resources available to you in a single
place that page is updated with every
release and includes access to dub and
beta versions I talked a little bit
about the Chrome browser enterprise
support offering that's an optional 24/7
email and phone access to Google support
that's something that you can visit our
website and contact sales to learn more
about we also have a team of enterprise
browser support specialists that can
help you and answer any questions you
might have about
chrome browser adoption in your
environment they can be reached at this
email alias here additionally as you
look at how new policies are made
available to you there's a complete
policy list that you can visit visiting
this URL here it'll give you good
visibility into the latest policies so
you can decide when it's the right time
for you go to go and update your policy
templates from chrome comm slash
Enterprise you can also visit the
release notes at this URL you'll also
have an opportunity there to sign up to
receive updated release notes
automatically via email and of course
the Google Chrome Enterprise Help Center
which is a great resource where you can
get all of the best documentation and
information that you need so that you
can best manage Chrome browser in your
environment I hope you found this
session helpful stay tuned for a live
Q&A we will be back in less than a
minute to answer your questions
you
let's take a look at some common
questions that we get around managing
Google Chrome updates one question we
get is whether release notes cover all
updates that's a good question what our
enterprise release notes really aim to
do is look at some of the changes to
Chrome browser the policies relevant
extensions that have the potential to
impact your enterprise we try and
highlight and focus on those major
changes so while you won't get an
exhaustive list of all the changes to
Chrome browser this is a great resource
and a great starting point to help you
as you plan out your testing and
rollouts
of new versions of Chrome browser
another question we get is around the
staged rollouts we've had some
enterprises ask if they can opt specific
users into getting immediate rollouts
instead of waiting for that staged
rollout
unfortunately the staged rollout works
in a way so that we're able to account
for any early potential issues and
challenges and address them so there's
no way to designate exactly who those
users are however if you do have a group
of users that you would like on the
latest version they might make for a
great option as your beta testing group
another question that sometimes comes up
is around our enterprise support
offering and whether some Google
customers already have access to Chrome
and our prize support for the browser
the support offering that I talked about
is a standalone offering and it gives
folks 24/7 access to reach out to Chrome
browser specialists that can help answer
questions about their deployments if you
do happen to have G suite you already
have access to this service but if
you're just using Chrome browser and
don't have other contracts with Google
in place this is a great option for how
IT can work directly with Google to make
sure Chrome browser is successful in
their environment we also sometimes get
questions around managing updates for
Mac users
you probably noticed that most of
today's session really focused on
Windows environments because we know
that is predominantly where most of our
enterprise users are however we do make
documentation available to help you
configure and manage policies including
managing updates for your Mac
environments and we do this via plist
and Kure encourage you to check out the
Help Center for all of that information
stay tuned for the next session see each
at how cloud composer orchestrates
containers and more thank you
you